皆さんはエグゾディアというカートご存知でしょうか
もうこれで撮った時点でいう企業は勝ちなんですでリゾテルカード5万円維持したよう
にそのて下って本当に揃うのかどうかっていうのはちょっとやってみようと思います
658,0008分の1の確率ケ嶺嶺151973%ということに忙しい詳しいか
おおぉおおおお
うぇい
はっはっはフェイザー
仕事しすぎでしょうかっ
ああああああ
ポンッはホフェアーを
これで高校&ローがあるからは彼のよ
4武人人
あっ法王が高くリスター
母いら切り返すん
t 4の
me
フォードね大混ぜ次いである茶屋ドローコードもあるぞ
わー
たちが没頭別でしたーー
モーゼルじゃあずしたん
あー頭の方に行ったかさん
をやっほぉじゃないですか
おおこれは
おおおおーーーー
あああああいう言葉だん
それはもう思うぞ
おおおおおお
mar espana
ええええええ
ええええええここにせしますっっ
500回目なんですけども3時間ほど経っても一向にエグゾディアがその動きはしませ
ん
全然500円やりました
こんな感じになっちゃうんですよちょっとこのままだと本当に難しい
なるほどを続けたいよ続けたいんですけどもちょっと厳しいと思っ
で100機を改造します優良カードの中にはドローね
ドローできるカードが何枚かあるんですけれどもその後何枚かちょっとこのデッキに
入れて
エクゾティアのカード
-ちょっと加速をしようと思うこれ連れでもなんでもないですどうぞなんではなくて
遊戯王のルールに従った上でちゃんとやってるんで
強欲で謙虚な壺はデッキの上から3枚カードを見てその中の1枚を手札に加えるという
かこれは手札のレベル8のモンスターを墓地に送って2枚ドローできるっていうか
でこれをやるためにちょっとレベル8のもう
スターみたいに入れますこれはい枚ドローした後にデータの闇属性モンスターを除外
するというか
いるぞてホテルたにくるようにドローの数を増やしてちょっと引き続き行っていうこと
に理由は家族なんですけどこれで多少足に合ってると思うんだよこれでちょっと続けて
いこうと思います
そりゃあしてっ
を
おおぉ air
クズ号結果当然使っていて3倍確認して1枚適度に加えれます
留学誘惑ダメくるっていうかれとるように使います
ブルーアイズを墓地に送って to draw
30枠使います
誰かなって
でも良さそうですねちょっとねまず光が見えたかもーん
皆さん
はい体調あの子がこのスリーブ壊しましたやるだけなんだよ
えっ去年ちょっと緊急事態なんですけどもスリーブが呼び家ちゃったので次も変える
作業に入ります
はいで日々新しくなって再出したのでー
よしっかー半経って今のところ最終がこちら736会になっておりまーす
もうてる気がしませんね
メガだけだって細くなってきましたではこの先を頑張っていきましょうよ
1 by ちょ20 c 4 e 000
めでぃあー
ああああああ
ありがとうござい
いやーまま5 o
いけなーい女性反射の席でまするフルあいつ ok
それでいい色良い美容
yeah
配布なふぉあ
旋回なりました
yeah
何味が強いのでございますもうなんかね
遊行カードすっ
ちょっとやなつったん
んだーよだってこれまずでみんなありがとねー
バイバイッ
a さんや海行ったところまだ行くぞてがいったんすることはありません始まってから
もう2時語って友だちはみんな帰ってしまいました
これさー
ブーシェ幅いーでー
1323会でちょっと休憩させてください
でないです
第8部の限界をきたんでちょっと仮眠を取らせていただいて
ひとたび1323ないからちょっと回していこうと思います
ただ目やエグゾディア
5人組の友達とが入るとさ
世界中が40人でもその5人が一緒にめぐり合う事ってこんなにも難しい
俺はそのね出会いのねー奇跡っていうものを伝えたいんでこれを通して
エグザンティアたちは1430会と巡り会えないんだよ天文学的な確率では皆がとやっ
てるの
wh
おっ
えっ滑るねー
キトキトキトキトキトピロ0やってまずきたポジ甘くっネイチャで今日は今日は基礎
ちょっちょうーだ言っ
んよっ
いやー1まずできた
まずできた一発でキター
まずできた今
やばいトリコぞ w
me
次母母を
1814会でエグゾディアは揃いました
あの
2日間かかりましたもう2ってまっ
ブーブスターいろいろスター nude
いって
あのうれしいとかというより一生終わらないんじゃないかと思っ
うすとホッとしてるん
def